99.9% of brick layers are men should we
have quotas for women is Brick laying
representative democracy that has
nothing to do with the question the
question is if there's evidence of
structural inequality and oppression
because women aren't precisely
represented at 50% in all professions at
all levels then why don't we have a
conversation about having women
represented in all professions at all
levels why do we talk about the sea
suite for example why do we talk about
politics and positions of power why
don't we talk about it across the board
but that's because it's power because
women are lazy and don't want to do hard
jobs you're welcome Jordan